[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hi, I'm Reto
Meier for The Developer Show.
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Indie Games Accelerator
is a new initiative
to support top Indie game
startups from India, Indonesia,
Malaysia, Pakistan the
Philippines, Singapore,
Thailand, and Vietnam, who
are looking to supercharge
their growth on Android.
To learn about the
benefits and apply today,
head on over to the post.
Firebase Unity Solutions
is a set of sample projects
and scripts that help you
utilize Firebase tools
and services for adding
cloud-based features
to your games being
built on Unity.
It's open source and on GitHub.
Head on over to the post
for details and the link.
We're lowering the
barrier to get started
on MongoDB Atlas and
Google Cloud Platform
by offering a free tier in
three supported regions.
The MongoDB NoSQL database
is hugely popular.
And the MongoDB
Atlas Cloud version
makes it easy to manage
on Google Cloud Platform.
Links to the docs and an
overview video are on the post.
The Transfer Appliance
is a high capacity server
that lets you transfer
large amounts of data
to Google Cloud Platform
quickly and securely.
It's recommended
if you're moving
more than 20 terabytes of
data, or data that would take
more than a week to upload.
And it's now generally
available in the US.
It also has a few new features.
Details and example
uses are on the post.
In June, BigQuery got a new data
type, new data input formats,
and finer cost controls.
Example queries and
screenshots are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Reto Meier for
The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Can you do any accents?
RETO MEIER: No.
Only this Australian one,
which I've got pretty nailed.
[LAUGHING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]